stefanie l r die delegierte auslösern
arbeitet seit sechs monaten in israel
wir können also noch alles gehen perfekt
sie ist zuständig für die besucher von
palästinensern in israelischen
gefängnissen überprüfte ihren
haftbedingungen und hält den kontakt zu
deren familien aufrecht
heute fährt sie in den gazastreifen in
palästinensisches autonomiegebiet jetzt
fahre ich nach gaza die alle zwei monate
das tue ich immer bevor ich die
israelische gefängnisse mit den meisten
insassen aus dem gaza-streifen besucher
im süden israels gibt es drei davon
zuerst besuche ich jetzt die angehörigen
von gefangenen die keine besucher
erhalten dürfen
ich spreche mit ihnen erkundige mich
nach neuigkeiten und nehme fotos mit das
alles überbringe ich dann den gefangenen
der gazastreifen ist abgeriegelt
israel kontrolliert die außengrenzen
stefanie muss drei checkpoints passieren
in der vorhergehenden folge hat stefanie
eller in der westbank palästinenser
getroffen
die harte vorwürfe gegen das israelische
militär erheben
ihk-präsident peter maurer verhandelte
am hauptsitz in genf mit eu
kommissionspräsident josé manuel barroso
mitten im kolumbianischen dschungel
organisierte abraham tobago einen
erste-hilfe-kurs für eine bewaffnete
gruppe
[Musik]
putin besuchte seine heimat im pandschir
tal
erinnerungen werden wach an die zeit in
denen er noch keine prothesen trug
[Musik]
im gazastreifen leben 1,5 millionen
palästinensern
über die hälfte sind flüchtlinge viele
müssen mit weniger als zwei dollar pro
tag auskommen
seit dem rückzug der israeli hat die
radikalislamische hamas das sagen
auseinandersetzungen zwischen
palästinensern und dem israelischen
militär prägen den alltag vor dem
geplanten besuch trifft der favela in
der delegation das ikk team
wir besuchen jetzt die mutter eines
gefangenen sie es noch einer seiner
wenigen angehörigen
sie ist sehr krank deshalb können sie
ihn nicht besuchen
sie ist blind und weil sie keine papiere
hat darf sie gar nicht verlassen
ich werde sie nach neuigkeiten fragen
damit ich diese ihren sohn mitteilen
kann
wenn ich den sohn nächster woche im
gefängnis besucher über bringe ich ihm
die nachrichten das wird nächsten
donnerstag
[Musik]
auch in der kolumbianischen dschungel
stadt gibt doch macht sich ikk bürochef
abraham beladung auf den weg er will dem
militär einen besuch abstatten vor
kurzem hatte einer bewaffneten gruppe
das humanitäre völkerrecht erklärt heute
trifft er die gegenseite ganz im sinne
der unparteilichkeit des ikk
es ist schwierig den kontakt mit allen
gruppierungen zu halten
am anfang versuchen sie dich dazu zu
bringen dass du stellung beziehen aber
eine dauerhafte beziehung ist nur
möglich wenn man an seiner linie fest
hält neutral unabhängig überparteilich
ist und einen guten job macht dann
nehmen sie das wahr und die beziehung
mit einfachen guten tag ich freue mich
euch wiederzusehen gut und wie geht's
dir sehr gut sehr gut
ich freue mich euch zu sehen alles top
ja ja gehe einfach durch den soldaten
will auch warum die kernaufgabe des ikk
erklären notleidenden in konflikten
beistehen und den menschenrechten
nachdruck verschaffen
wir sind unabhängig
was heißt das
dass wir von niemandem abhängig sind
wer erhalten zwar geld das ist notwendig
aber wir müssen niemandem rechenschaft
ablegen
niemand sagt uns macht dies oder jenes
aber ich spreche auch mit kriminellen
banken in einem vertraulichen dialog und
immer im interesse derjenigen die das
ikk beschützt opfer des krieges
das können soldaten der region kämpft
zivilisten oder gefangene seien
je besser das militär über die arbeit
des ikk bescheid weiß umso ungehinderter
können die delegierten ihrer arbeit
nachgehen
jetzt wird abraham zurück nach gibt eine
schwierige aufgabe steht ihm bevor
[Musik]
wir sind zurück in gaza stadt
stefanie l und field offices cellcept
besuchen oben fahren der izone vor 23
jahren verhaftet wurde
wie geht es um das ist davon wie geht es
ihnen
nehmen sie sich doch einen stuhl
wie geht es mit der gesundheit sollen
wir uns draußen hinsetzen
oh ja draußen vor der türe
ich hole stühle wie geht es ihrer
gesundheit
gott sei gedankt und möge er auch der
gesundheit schenken ihnen auch ich war
schon im juli hier
ich weiß nachdem ich mit faris
gesprochen habe du hast ihn getroffen ja
ich habe es gesehen im juli ja im juli
es geht ihm gut und er fragt ob sie
genügend fleisch und erinnern sie sich
daran
wer fleisch und tun es ist richtig dass
sie fleisch und thun essen sagte er
das ist gut für ihre gesundheit es geht
ihm gut er war froh über ihre nachricht
ist er gesund ja er ist gesund und er
sagt dass alles in ordnung sei sie
fielen ihm und mir fehlte noch mehr
ihnen fehlt er noch mehr ich habe ihn
seit zwölf jahren nicht mehr gesehen
meine liebe ich schreibe ihre
nachrichten auf wenn ich nächste woche
treffe kann ich sie ihm geben und er
wird erleichtert zu
ja das ist gut
ich nehme einen stift um die nachricht
für ihren sohn fades aufzuschreiben
uns geht es gut wir umarmen dich mach
dir keine sorgen
gott ist mächtig ich hoffe so sehr dass
du am ende des monats aus dem gefängnis
entlassen wird
dann singt er von gott beschütze ich
rufe sie an und hatte sie auf dem
laufenden
geht in frieden und viel erfolg alles
gute später erfahren wir dass die
hoffnung von faris einmal mehr
enttäuscht wurde ihr sohn bleibt weiter
in israelischer haft
[Musik]
karben die hauptstadt afghanistans im
orthopädie zentrum des ikk ist heute ein
ganz besonderer tag
ein sportlicher wettkampf ist geplant
ein basketballturnier mit rollstühlen
einige spieler trainieren schon früh
morgens
währenddessen kümmert sich direktor
nacho modin um einen patienten dessen
bein nicht fachgerecht abmontiert wurde
das bein hätte nicht unterhalb sondern
oberhalb des knies entfernt werden
sollen eine solche amputation bringt
viele probleme für die prothese mit sich
diesen teil hätten sie weglassen können
wenn sie die amputation richtig gemacht
hätten wäre es einfach wenn der patient
die prothese trägt ist diese teil länger
als der andere
es ist zwar möglich eine prothese
anzufertigen
aber sie ist nicht optimal wenn er sitzt
kann er das knie nicht wollen diesem
fall müssen wir mit den chirurgen
besprechen
putin ist selber hoch betroffen nach
einer minenexplosion trägt er zwei
beinprothesen jetzt muss er sich beeilen
denn ein wichtiger auftritt steht ihm
bevor
[Musik]
wir sind im osten des kongo in der
provinz nord-kivu in der kleinstadt
toowoomba ist der krieg präsent auch
wenn er nicht sichtbar ist die menschen
vertrauen auf gott mal auf die regierung
kein verlass ist das ikk betreibt hier
eine sogenannte basis während unseres
drews ist die rebellengruppe m23 noch
aktiv
ursula kayali ist schon viele jahre war
delegierte sie ist in zürich als ursula
gubler aufgewachsen
heute organisiert sie einen markt für
einheimische
bezahlt wird mit coupons einer eigenen
währung
und wie hat das doch wie und verschluss
wie so einfach will sie durchaus
nützliche sachen sind dass es zu einer
sitzung der kupon für die vorrangig
trainer haben und die gutbrod ist ja
eigentlich mehr geld und vor dem monitor
schluss ha und zweitens natürlich die
klk und rot grün ist der sauer mit dem
emblem ja dann 20 sind das denn jetzt
ist weg und mitarbeiter des
kongolesischen roten kreuzes
unterstützen die hilfsaktion
die fahrt im konvoi dauert eine stunde
was in anbetracht der straßen hier
gleich nebenan ist das ziel der aktion
ist die menschen mit dem nötigsten zu
versorgen
auf der flucht vor bewaffneten
gruppierungen haben sie alles verloren
kleider werkzeuge und matratzen
in diesem entlegenen gebiet einen markt
zu organisieren ist aufwendig der aufbau
dauert zwei tage
ursula dirigiert die zwei dutzend helfer
des lokalen roten kreuzes nach und nach
nimmt der markt gestalt an
zu stempeln ist wichtig damit die
coupons wirklich klar als unsere
erkennbar sind
jede familie erhält gutscheine im wert
von 120 dollar so kann jede familie
selber entscheiden was sie am
dringendsten benötigt anders als wenn
sie herkömmliche hilfspakete erhielten
das verleihe der menschenwürde sagt
ursula
[Musik]
in kolumbien ist abnahm tobago zur hilfe
gerufen worden am fluss einer kleinen
stadt wurde eine leiche entdeckt es gibt
hinweise dass der mann von einer
bewaffneten gruppe getötet wurde
leichen werden bisweilen mit minen
versehen als warnung für die angehörigen
bei seiner ankunft erfährt abraham dass
der tote nun doch gebaut und zur
identifizierung nach quito gebracht
worden sei gerüchteweise ist zu hören es
sei eine vergeltungstat gewesen
das opfer aber mit einer rivalisierenden
gruppe kollaboriert
wir sind jetzt in der stadt in der es
geschah wir versuchen die familie zu
treffen und herauszufinden was passiert
ist und deren aussagen zu dokumentieren
hoffentlich können wir etwas tun aber
ich denke es wird schwierig mit ihnen zu
sprechen
erst trifft abraham die angehörigen
später will er die bewaffnete gruppe
kontaktieren die hinter der tat vermutet
wir machen alles nur mit ihrem
einverständnis
ich kannte nur wenn sie mir das sagen
nun muss ich ihm ein paar fragen stellen
das tut mir leid da durch sie nach ihrem
alter fragen wie die alte ich bin 43
jahre alt und sie sind 69 oder es ist
eine schwierige geschichte sie ist
komplex und ich verstehe ihre ängste wir
haben jetzt verschiedene möglichkeiten
erstens wir unternehmen nur etwas wenn
sie das erlauben weiter kann ich über
den fall sprechen ohne ihre namen zu
erwähnen oder ich kann ihren namen den
familien und dann kann ich auch sagen
die familie ist beunruhigt sie möchte
wissen und sie möchte wissen wieso wieso
wir sind nicht unruhig sie sollen uns
sagen warum warum ich kann fragen sie so
singen getötet haben ob sie auch etwas
gegen sie haben
also dann passen sie auf sich auf sie
auch wieder sehen wenn ich hübsche
kinder sie haben ja eine meiner töchter
geld ist do 7
wie groß du bist auf dem heimweg nach
gibt so begegnet uns der leichenwagen
er bringt den toten sohn nach hause
[Musik]
wir sind im ikk büro in gaza stadt ist
der familie und ihr kollege massa haben
am vortag um paris besucht heute
erwarten sie die frau und die schwester
eines anderen palästinensischen
häftlingen grundsätzlich gehen wir nur
zu der familie eines gefangenen wenn die
angehörigen zu krank sind
[Musik]
normalerweise kommt die familie hierher
wie veronika pussy siehst ukraine rinnen
und zum islam konvertiert jemand der
palästinenser die rabussier wurde in der
ukraine vom israelischen geheimdienst
verhaftet
ihm wird vorgeworfen ein hamas aktivist
und ein terrorist zu sein
das sei nicht wahr sagt die frau sie
prangert die haftbedingungen
aber wie so könnt ihr die menschenrechte
nicht verteidigen
auch nicht das elementarste recht das
leicht auf eine menschenwürdige umgebung
und auf eigene kleider
wieso seid ihr so machtlos das frage ich
euch stefanie erklärt der frau oder sich
das ikk für bessere bedingungen in
israelischen gefängnissen einsätze
jedoch keine direkten machtbefugnisse
hätte
ich möchte von dir persönlich und vom
ganzen ikk wissen in welchem zustand
seine zelle ist sein bett und alles
andere gibt es tageslicht in der zelle
dass sie meine frage an euch beim
nächsten gefängnis besuch bei abus
easybooking stéphanie die wünsche seiner
frau überbringen
zudem wird sie ihm einige kleider
mitbringen ist der verließ zweitägige
besuch im gazastreifen ist nun zu ende
wärst du heute zurück
ja ich fahre zurück nach tel aviv und
wann kommst du wieder an einem
wochenende im keller
innerhalb von gaza gibt es verschiedene
sicherheitszone
diese gelten auch für mitarbeitende von
humanitären organisationen in diesem
teil darf sich stefanie nur im konvoi
bewegen
[Musik]
die universität körper hartmut ihn als
experten eingeladen
wir bleiben bis 15 uhr hier dürfen wir
alle zu diesem seminar sind sie
bewaffnet
nein wir haben keine waffen
wie spät ist es viertel vor
warum setzen wir uns noch ein paar
minuten hin
das seminar findet jedes jahr statt
putin trifft alte bekannte schön sie zu
sehen
erinnern sie sich an mich sehr gut wie
geht's wer ich war bestimmt neun jahren
nicht mehr hier
ja es ist lange her amica rockerkriegs
reggae seminar bot ihn seine große
erfahrung weitergeben
das ikea hat vor 26 jahren 1988 mit dem
orthopädie programm begonnen
damals fing er mit dieser arbeit an
repräsentiert den ärzten den patienten
aus dem orthopädie zentrum dieser
patient ist aus kandahar
schauen sie diesen bruder wurde das bein
amputiert
ein langer herausragender stumpfe übrig
das knie funktioniert nicht mehr und ist
steif
er kann dieses gelenk nicht benutzen
er kann es nicht beugen für ihn müssen
wir eine spezial prothese anfertigen
wenn er sitzt fragt das knie heraus dass
eine knie ist hinten das andere vorne
das ist nicht schön putins appell
amputationen besser auf die prothesen
abzustimmen findet gehör
die positiven rückmeldungen auf seinen
vortrag sind eine große befriedigung
waren so glücklich mit meiner
präsentation meine güte
sie sagten sie hätten wirklich nicht an
diese sachen gedacht die hin sagte
[Musik]
sind sie ein bisschen stolz nun meine
einstellung ist folgen
wenn ich etwas sinnvolles für behinderte
menschen erreichen kann bin ich mehr als
dann würde ich so etwas auch hundertmal
hmm
[Musik]
in krumbach in der provinz nord-kivu ist
es abend geworden
die delegierten dürfen das haus nicht
mehr verlassen das wäre zu gefährlich
jetzt tauchen gedanken auf die beitrag
keinen platz haben
ursula kayali erzählt ihrer kollegin von
ihrem einsatz in chart damals ging es um
leben und tod eines fans sind wir mit
dem auto zur residenz zurückgefahren
banditen haben uns aufgelauert
ich wurde von einer kugel getroffen und
verletzt
ich habe viel blut aber per zufall
hatten sich dort vor kurzem europäische
streitkräfte eingerichtet ein chirurgen
team hat mich eine halbe stunde später
evakuiert und noch in derselben nacht
operiert was mich fast am meisten
beunruhigt ist nicht dass mir etwas
passieren könnte
nicht dass ich das möchte aber es ist
mir der kummer den das meinen
angehörigen bereiten würde
vor allem seien es lange dauert eine
entführung oder so wären so unglücklich
und ich würde mir solche vorwürfe machen
dass sie das ertragen müssen
das beschäftigt nicht
seit sie dem tod in die augen geschaut
hat aber sie mehr respekt vor dem leben
sagt ursula
[Musik]
wie schützt man die zivilbevölkerung in
bewaffneten konflikten dies das thema
einer konferenz des departements des
äusseren in bern nika lka-präsident
peter maurer ist als redner geladen
der ehemalige chef diplomat trifft alte
bekannte wir sind im jahr 2013 als ueli
maurer noch bundespräsident war
gastgeber ist außenminister didier
burkhalter
gegen tag herr burkhalter geht es ihnen
gut
ich gehe von einem präsidenten auger zum
nächsten in der schweiz wimmelt es von
präsidentin maurer ja muss die hände der
guten präsidenten schütteln darüber
richtig abstimmen weil ich freue mich
gut an wir später nur den stunde
ich kann nicht mit ihnen essen nein ich
auch wenn alles gutgeht fliege ich am
sonntag nach damaskus und in die türkei
[Gelächter]
alle werden gleich davon rennen
nein so schlimm ist ich fliege am
sonntag in die türkei um ein paar
personen von der opposition zu treffen
dann am montagabend damaskus wenn alles
gut läuft
für den körper präsidenten ist diese
konferenz pflicht wird sie für mich
eigentlich zwei wichtige themen und vom
programm erstens thema vor der attacke
war für ca
große politik ist der schutz vor die
zivilbevölkerung in bewaffneten
konflikten und da schließen da die
leighton der erde wird in der
gleichnamigen burg alter und ehemalige
kollegen im etat doch es muss vieles
gespräche über die zusammenarbeit
zwischen der schweiz und damit kroate
zusammenarbeit wo mir natürlich
außerordentlich schätze es ist erstens
das darf man nie vergessen wo vor der
schweiz zum mikro und der trikot von
humanitärer botschafter der schweiz es
ist verriet zusammenarbeit wichtig ist
weil schweiz doch das land ist wo man
die von den ideen von der politischen
ausrichtung von der humanitäre politik
von der schweiz natürlich
außerordentlich viel gemeinsamkeit und
unterstützt
dann ergriff der gastgeber das wort
meine damen und herren an dieser tagung
gehen wir der frage nach dem schutz von
zivilpersonen nach eine zentrale
herausforderung ist das einhalten und
die umsetzung des humanitären
völkerrechts
dieses ist so weit entwickelt wie nie
zuvor
und trotzdem ist der schutz bei
bewaffneten konflikten ungenügend das
liegt nicht nur einen gesetzeslücken
sondern auch an fehlendem respekt
gegenüber existierenden recht das recht
ersetzt den fehlenden willen der
menschen nicht eine enge zusammenarbeit
des wkk mit dem außen departements
sinnvoll
maurer sei ein angenehmer partner sagt
burkhardt ich schätze seine arbeitsweise
sehe er geht in sachen auf den grund es
gewissenhaft nicht voreingenommen und er
reflektiert und was ihn wirklich
interessiert ist das wohl der menschen
die großzügige seite der schweiz noch
einmal seine wichtigste botschaft der
bessere schutz von notleidenden menschen
in konflikt und krisengebieten die
größtmögliche zahl von menschen zu
schützen und ihnen zu helfen und es im
heutigen fall in mehr als 80 ländern
dieser welt
[Applaus]
[Musik]
nach langer trockenzeit hat es in nord
kivu angefangen zu regnen
ausgerechnet jetzt wo der markt eröffnet
werden sollen
die menschen begegnen dem regen mit
gelassenheit denn das wasser ist
grundlage für das leben
man richtet sich ein auch ursula muss
sich gedulden der regel bringt unser
zeitplan durcheinander aber wipro
visieren ist sie sich gewohnt
[Musik]
nadine ist zurück im orthopädie zentrum
in kabul
er muss die liegengebliebene arbeit
erledigen
draußen ertönt gleich der angriff zum
nationalen rollstuhl basketball turnier
willkommen zum finale des nationalen
frühlings turniers denkt daran ihr kennt
keine ball über gerne machen
der amerikanische markt hat die spieler
trainiert lasst uns ein großartiges
finale spiel haben spielt fair spielt
hart und genießt es
der ex profispieler sitzt selber im
rollstuhl
seit drei jahren kommt er immer wieder
hierher das macht mir am meisten freude
zu sehen wie die jungs über sich selbst
hinauswachsen und zu männern
heranwachsen
auch die älteren spiele sind voller
zuversicht und selbst 8 das gibt mir so
viel kraft sie in diesem punkt zu sehen
[Musik]
die bewohner der umliegenden dörfer
warten sehnlichst auf den markt denn
viele von ihnen haben alles verloren
wie diese mutter von vier kindern wir
nennen ihren namen nicht um sie zu
schützen
zeitweise kämpften hier dutzende
bewaffnete gruppen um die macht die
zivilisten gerieten zwischen die fronten
sie haben erfahren was es heißt wenn
plünderungen und vergewaltigungen zur
kriegsführung gehören die ganze
situation begann abrupt
[Musik]
plötzlich war nichts mehr sicher
am schlimmsten war es nachts wenn wir
schlafen gingen wir mussten sogar mitten
in der nacht fliehen
manche rannten so schnell weg dass sie
sogar vergaßen ihre kinder mitzunehmen
einige flohen ohne kleider
fast nackt so wie sie eben gerade
geschaffen hatten
schutzlos waren sie den bewaffneten
ausgeliefert es wurde immer
schrecklicher sie nahmen alles sie
vergewaltigten auch uns frauen sogar
schwangere und junge mädchen
niemand konnte uns retten die frau und
ihre familie versteckten sich in den
wäldern
jetzt wo die situation stabiler ist sind
sie zurückgekehrt
ursula kayali will nun den markt
eröffnen noch ein paar kleine hinweise
für den tag auf dem markt bieten 48
händler viele wichtige artikel für den
haushalt an
nehmen sie sich doch zeit erst alles
anzuschauen um die richtige wahl zu
treffen
[Musik]
400 menschen sind begierig auf das
angebot
das ikrk hat vorher die dringendsten
bedürfnisse abgeklärt
auch die frau die mit uns gesprochen hat
ist dabei
[Musik]
ursula kontrolliert ob sich die händler
an die abgesprochenen preise halten
[Musik]
die frau hat sich ganz genau überlegt
was sie mit den ikk gutscheinen kauft
damit ihre kinder zur schule gehen
können ist es wichtig sie gut
einzukleiden
ich freue mich riesig
ich bin überglücklich über das alles ich
finde gar keine worte
meinem sohn wird es jetzt viel besser
geht und alle kinder haben neue kleider
wie die frau haben zahlreiche familien
vom markt profitiert das ikrk hat
insgesamt gutscheine im wert von 200.000
franken verteilt
zu hause werden die schätze ausgepackt
und begutachtet für alle ist etwas dabei
die jacke aus kunstpelz ist für die
älteste tochter
sie schützt wenn der feucht kalten nebel
kommt
[Musik]
am kongress in bern haben ihk-präsident
maurer und der staub des departements
des äusseren die gelegenheit für
gespräche genutzt
es ging um einen gemeinsamen fahrplan
relativ klare vorstellungen wie das so
der wichtige komplett durch der jury und
auch gar nicht an und so dass man diese
müssen abstimmen
in der konkreten aktivitäten von rig
count auf der schweizerische dezember
vor ort tätig ist also es ist eine ganze
serie von thema mit sammer gesprochen
herr jung doch qualität 16 14 nächste
jahre formulierte
weil maurers familie in bern wohnt hat
er heute einen kurzen einblick
wer sportliche 58-jährige ist hier
meistens mit dem rad unterwegs
stadt santa casa di goethe nach syrien
und die türkei
im orthopädie zentrum in kabul sind wir
mitten im nationalen rollstuhl
basketball turnier behinderte sportler
aus ganz afghanistan messen sich unter
großer anteilnahme des publikums
ich habe angst dass kabul verliert im
finale schließlich tritt korb und gegen
masar i scharif an
die jungen männer geben alles
[Applaus]
[Musik]
aber auch hier gilt das motto mitmachen
ist wichtiger als gewinnen
[Applaus]
zur rehabilitation behinderte sollten
spielen können sollten ihren platz in
der gesellschaft haben wie andere auch
ich freue mich dass sie dieses turnier
veranstalten das spielt für mich keine
rolle wer gewinnt und wer verliert
sie alle sind gewinner
[Applaus]
so gibt es denn auch medaillen und
pokale für alle die jungen männer nehmen
sie voller stolz entgegen für einmal
sind sie die stars
dass er füllt sie mit mut und zuversicht
für den harten alltag in der letzten
folge nimmt uns natur die ihn mit nach
masar i scharif
das schicksal eines patienten fühlten
auf
[Musik]
präsident peter maurer feuer das 150
jährige bestehen des ikk und sorgt für
die gute sache
abraham dobler bringt vertriebenen
indios hoffnung und versucht ihr leid zu
lindern
im hauptsitz in genf als der funny lr
ein wichtiges gespräch es geht um ihre
zukunft
[Musik]